استطلاع اخر التطورات معنا الان من غلاف
غزه مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري الجديد
نجوان فيما يتعلق ب الاشتباكات بالاسلحه
الرشاشه التي سجلت شرق جباليه على وجه
الخصوص بالفعل ازدهار كانت هناك اصوات
لاشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله
سمعناها من هنا وتاتي من منطقه شرق جباليا
تحديدا وهذه المنطقه من الواضح بانها تشهد
اشتباكات ما بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه و
وما بين قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي
تسعى منذ ايام ربما الى احراز اي تقدم
ايضا في هذه المنطقه رغم انسحاب غالبيه
قوات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من مناطق
الشمال لكن من الواضح ان حتى العمليات
التي يصفها الجيش الاسرائيلي بالمحدود
ومحدده الاهداف في هذه المناطق ما زال
يواجه فيها مشاكل ومازال يجد صعوبه في
التقدم حتى عندما يتعلق الامر بمثل هذه
العمليات المحدده والمحدوده وفقا لتسميته
وهذا يعني ان
هناك المقاومه الفلسطينيه تتصدى وتواجه
وتشتبك ايضا في كافه المحاور التي يحاول
الاحتلال التقدم فيها وسواء كان ذلك في
المناطق الشماليه ولكن ايضا في المناطق
الجنوبيه بطبيعه الحال وعندما نتحدث عن
المناطق الشماليه فهي المناطق التي اعلن
عمليا الجيش الاسرائيلي اتمام عملياته
الكبيره فيها سواء كان عمليات القصف
والاستهداف واعلن بانه قام بتفكيك الاطر
العسكريه لحركه حماس تحديدا لكتائب القسام
وايضا اتم سيطرته الناريه واعاد انتشار
قواته وتموضع في هذه المناطق لكن مع ذلك
من الواضح ان اي عمليه له
في مناطق بيت لاهيه وبيت حنون ومنطقه
جباليا والاحياء الشماليه ايضا من مدينه
غزه ومدينه غزه يواجه فيها صعوبات جمه
تتعلق
بالقتال الضاري الدائر ايضا مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه قبل ايام قليله اشارت صحيفه ها
ارتس نقلا عن مسؤولين عسكريين وامني في
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه بان الجيش
بدا يرصد عمليات اعاده تاهيل من قبل حركه
حماس وكتائب القسام ل لكتائب العسكريه في
منطقه الشمال تحديدا وبدا يعين قاضه جدد
بدل هؤلاء الذين تم اغتيالهم خلال عمليات
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في اشاره ايضا
لما كان قد صرح به وزي رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش هرتي هاليفي قبل ايام عندما قال بان
الجيش قد تبدا عمليات تاكل وفقا لوصفه
بالانجازات التي حققها الجيش في المناطق
الشماليه اذا لم يتم وضع تصور سياسي
للمرحله المقبله بمعنى ان ترك الجيش لهذه
المناطق من الجانب الاسرائيلي سيخلق حاله
فراغ
واليه ستعود حركه حماس التي كان الجيش قد
اعلن بانه فكك اطورها اطورها العسكريه لكن
من الواضح ان هذا التفكيك يعني الذي تحدث
عنه الجيش الاسرائيلي غير دقيق لاننا ما
زلنا نرى حتى في بياناته التي يصدرها يص
يوميا عن عملياته نرى بان هناك الكثير من
الوقائع التي تشير الى اشتباكات متواصله
مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه في البلدات
والاحياء الشماليه في قطاع غزه حاليا هناك
اصوات انفجارات في هذه المناطق وتحليق
ايضا للطائرات الحربيه اي على المناطق
الشماليه او فوق المناطق الشمال
نعم هو تحليق لطائرات حربيه وفي منطقه ما
استطيع ان ارى من هنا دخان كثيف ينبعث
وائل ربما تستطيع دخان كثيف بدا ينبعث
الان
وائل هنا هناك انفجار كبير
جدا في هذه
المنطقه الان اذا بعد سماع ضوي انفجار
كبير هذه الاطراف الشرقيه لمنطقه
بيت حانون وقد تكون ايضا جزء من المناطق
الشرقيه هذا الانفجار زويه اخ نشاهد صور
الانفجار في هذه اللحظات من
زاويه اخرى من غلاف غزه وحتى الان لا يعرف
ما هو المستهدف وانما هي المناطق الشماليه
شمال قطاع
غزه موقع هذا الانفجار هل لك ان تحدديه
لنا
نجوان
نعم هو يعني من هذا الموقع نرى بانه في
الاطراف الشرقيه لمنطقه بيت حانون وهي
متداخله ايضا في بعض المواقع مع اطراف
منطقه جباليا ازدهار وبما ان كل ما يعني
من شهود عيان من داخل قطاع غزه يتحدثون عن
ان الاشتباكات الضاريه حاليا تدور في
منطقه شرق جباليا فربما هي جزء من هذه
المنطقه نحن نقف مباشره قباله قريه ام
النصر ومنطقه بيت حانون في اقصى شمال قطاع
غزه ومناطق بيت لاهيه لكن هذا الانفجار
ياتي من هذه المنطقه المتداخله عمليا ما
بين الاطراف الشرقيه لمنطقه بيت حانون
وجبالي طيله الوقت يوم امس وقفنا في منطقه
مقابله لجبال وراينا ان هناك طيله الوقت
اصوات ايضا انفجارات واصوات اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الرشاشه وقبل قليل ايضا كانت
هناك اصوات لاشتباكات بالاسلحه والرشاشات
الثقيله وهذا يدل على ان هناك ايضا قتال
واشتباكات عنيفه تجري ما بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وما بين قوات الاحتلال غالبيه
الاحيان ما نسمعه من هنا يكون جراء اصوات
انفجارات ينفذها جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تحديدا قوات الهندسه وفي بياناته طيله
الوقت يتحدث عن انه يقوم بتفجير مبان يرصد
فيها حركه لمقاومين فلسطينيين او بنى
تحتيه وانفاق لكن هذه كانت اغلب الظن انها
غاره لانه كان هناك تحرك للطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي ونحن معكم على الهواء مباشره
كان هناك صوت دوي انفجار وكان هناك تحرك
واضح فوق هذه المنطقه للطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي وليس فقط للمروحيات بل كانت
اصوات طائرات حربيه تحلق في هذا الموقع
وسمعنا صوت انفجار وها هو اثار هذا القصف
واضحه جدا لهذا الدخان المنبعث من هذه
المنطقه في الاطراف الشرقيه لمنطقه بيت
حانون وجباليا ونحن نتحدث عن المناطق التي
بدا الاجتياح البري منها ازدهار قبل في ال
26 والع تحديدا من اكتوبر الماضي ومن هنا
ايضا بدات اكبر عمليات للقصف الجوي
والمدفعي مع بدايه هذه الحرب حيث تم تدم
جزء كبير جدا من هذه المناطق بالكامل مسحت
مناطق واسعه جراء عمليات القصف التي
تواصلت لثلاثه اسابيع قب قبل ان تبدا
الدبابات والمدرعات والقوات البريه ايضا
باجتياح هذه المناطق مع بدايه الحرب ولكن
حتى الان بعد اكثر من 100 يوم ما زلنا نرى
هذا الاستهداف وهذا القصف وهذه العمليات
المتواصله سواء كان بالقصف المدفعي اوم
والقصف الجوي ولكن ايضا بعمليات تفجير
واسعه وهذا اليوم فقط في بيان الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي تحدث عن ثلاثه وقائع
او ثلاث وقائع اي استهدف فيها مقاومين
فلسطينيين في عملياته خلال ال 24 الماضيه
في المناطق الشماليه الان ايضا تفجير اخر
لكن ياتي من منطقه بيت لاهيه ازدهار اذا
العمليات مستمره للاستهداف في هذه المناطق
ايضا بالاضافه الى قصف مدفع عنيف وقصف جوي
يطال ويستهدف مناطق مخيمات الوسط والمناطق
الجنوبيه تحديدا منطقه خان يونس شكرا
جزيلا لك من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري